good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and Nancy P were going to be
studying today is scp-797
[Music]
4 meters special containment procedures
scp-797 point 4 meters from each side of
the pool
medicinal center is to be marked as the
zone of denial with a second perimeter
extending the zone of denial out an
extra 50 meters to be regarded as the
restricted zone signs placed on the
perimeter of the zone of denial must
state no unauthorized entrance in the
following languages English French
Swahili Luwak si que Congo and Luke
Wanda when testing access is to be
restricted to class DS no other
foundation personnel are to be allowed
entrance future installation of security
cameras around the hospital is a
possibility description scp-797 of human
congo trypanosomiasis a parasitic
protozoa also known as the African
sleeping sickness inhabiting the
abandoned medicinal center located in
built by missionaries in 18 SC P 793 s
first known appearance was documented in
19 the hospital was subsequently
relinquished from use years after to the
exponential growth of a CP 793 but it
was never demolished due to
superstitions the populace and the
prominent thing and tribes helped in
1955 the hospital was secured by the
foundation as CP 793 in its passive form
does not appear to exist unless a
suitable human host enters the zone of
denial which is currently estimated to
be thirteen point four meters from any
point or
the hospital when a human enters the
zone of denial the organism will appear
spontaneously inside the human
circulatory system unlike a normal form
of Japan oh so myiasis which has a
limited rate of reproduction the
reproductive rate of scp-797
for example when a subject is at the
edge of the zone of denial as CP 793
will reproduce that 5% the speed of
human congo trypanosomiasis but once
inside the hospital where reproductive
capability is at a constant
scp-797 Dru percent the speed of their
cousin symptoms appeared to be
dissimilar to those of normal congo
trypanosomiasis with a notable increase
in hysteria and swelling of the lymph
nodes the opposite occurs when a subject
leaves the zone of denial the
reproductive rate decreases and the
parasites will spontaneously disappear
with no visible signs of cell death
somatic cells whose death can be
attributed to scp-797 suddenly occurs
not as the result of general somatic
mitosis the symptoms will fade to those
of earlier stages from the neurological
phase going to the Hema lymphatic stage
etc until there are no signs of the
protists existing when a human victim
exits the zone of denial one final note
about possible human death as the result
of scp-797
once the deceased are rescued from the
maximum reproductive zone somatic cells
appear immediately and any remaining
instances of scp-797 dividuals often
recall extreme pain due to the
reconstruction of their body mostly
regarded as something along the lines of
thousands of knives piercing their body
and have no recollection of ever
entering the zone of denial or any
knowledge of scp-797 93's reversal
effects only regard any damage it causes
a human bodies whose deaths are
attributed to other causes such as
normal human Kongo trypanosomiasis will
not be affected as CP 793 does not
appear on anything that is not living
human tissue appearance of scp-797
to the zone of denial and is limited to
the fraction of the human that is in the
zone of denial items brought out of the
hospital have no unique effect attached
to them addendum SCP 793 EXO j1
regarding site demolition of scp-797 tan
Chong mang PhD date/time the medicinal
center otherwise known as the residence
of the infamous scp-797 was subject to
the possibility of sterilization
proposals generally suggested a wide
variety of explosive materials typically
based compounds controversy over the
destruction of Euclid class specimens
has always been a major topic of
discussion within the foundation the
general consensus about the termination
of scp-797 a logistic continued
containment of SCP 793 despite continued
controversy over the topic the details
for the defense of continued containment
procedures are as follows
a SCP 793 really poses no real threat no
permanent death has occurred from the
actions of the ghost trypanosomiasis be
the hospital's architectural structures
seems to be continually sturdy and shows
no signs of serious decay suggesting
structural and vulnerability we don't
think this should be tested at least not
yet see as reference to the consensus we
have no knowledge of what would happen
on attempted destruction of the hospital
and finally D angering of the closeby
tribes in the area we would also like to
discuss possible reclassification of
scp-797
[Music]
addendum scp-797 regarding zone of
denial fluctuation reported by mark foo
liu via e-mail edited for better
comprehension it seems that a few of the
tests into zone of denial have found
that the boundary is far further away
than what it was used to be not know
what do I don't know what to do about
this date/time help I do not know what
to do the thing the zone of denial keeps
changing date/time please help it the
zone of denial is growing bigger and
bigger and bigger now date/time other
similar message from mark foo Liu and
other personnel stationed in the area
has brought intrigued investigation by
foundation assets in North America
confirmation of zone of denial distance
fluctuation is currently pending okay
that about does it for today thank you
all for listening and you are all
dismissed
goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to Desmond Hoskins Andre Bashar dr.
mortis Cody tench
Pierce M Hamlin sy7 actual rebellion
fidelia's untie verbal if you would like
a personalized thank you at the end of
each of my videos on some other cool
stuff as well
visit patreon.com forward slash the
volgen thank you
[Music]
you
[Music]